and with that please join me in
welcoming Natasha Leon and Coleman
Domingo
hello hello hi what a what a show that
was Coleman Coleman Domingo my real life
friend
um so uh something in Passing Strange I
just became maybe my uh my thematic
North Star for our talk here
today uh I think you said uh something
like it's it's God's work I'm just a
vessel yes did that happen in that clip
uh I just want to say pretty agnostic
maybe a Satanist but on a deep deep
spiritual basis uh Coleman Domingo is
perhaps one of the heaviest hitters I
know in my life of all time and uh maybe
no person is that truer of in the sense
of uh
genuinely uh touched in this sort of
very
grounded uh humble really touched by the
Arts uh can you maybe speak to that a
little bit maybe you might know what I
mean I I think it might thank you first
of all thank you all for being here this
is really
[Applause]
lovely you always think oh they're doing
something for me will anybody
come and then I poked my head out and I
saw all these faces and I was little
overwhelmed to be honest and thank you
for
coming I think I you know I started out
my career about 33 years ago and I I
think because I maybe it's I think I
started in San
Francisco and where it was really just
about trying to find your way into being
an artist and I thought I wanted to be
an actor and then I think it turned me
into a a multi-dimensional artist
because I had questions I had I felt
like I had a place theater theater is
where I started and I really felt like I
had a place in storytelling um I I don't
think that naturally I came from I come
from a bunch of storytellers people who
just like they know how to tell stories
in my family but I think that um when I
was in college my one of my teachers
told me he believed that I had a gift in
this and I was always a shy kid I was on
the school newspaper and things like
that I was I never thought people in
high school would never imagine that I'd
be doing what I'm doing I wouldn't
imagine I was doing what I was doing but
I watch people a lot and I think that
possibly my journey has been about like
you know I started out when to be an
actor and then I became an artist
because I just wanted to play and figure
things out and and cover uh who we are
and i' and I've always thought of it I
think even early on as it being an act
of service you know I felt like oh this
is how I tell story I think that's what
I mean uh is you maybe more than anyone
in my life uh is truly the living
embodiment of the thing you know like
some people um just are the real deal
and they say uh uh you know Walks Like
the truth it smells like the truth or
whatever a a spiritual principle is uh
you know like 1+ 1 equals 2 or whatever
it's it never equals three and you more
than maybe anyone I know really is the
embodiment of I what I see in your work
is that it's of service to the peace
it's not an ego trip which is so crazy
because if anyone deserve to have the
ultimate ego it's callon Domingo uh and
you see so many kind of you know uh
nobody turnup trucks roll into this town
they just like they drop out of The
Ether and they say they have names and
I'm like sir ma'am I think you just uh
want to be famous when you grow up and
then somebody like you uh actually puts
in the work and is the real deal and
lives the life that takes the time that
takes those Decades of being a
journeyman and holy shit when A Moment
Like This arrives for you I mean you
have lived a life in service to the art
didn't matter if it was acting directing
producing what you know what it was the
size of the role Off Broadway blackbox
Theater or the big leagues but it's like
a holy shit the moment finally caught up
and it is that spiritual principle of
like the most basic one which is karma
you know what I mean like you're a
fucking piece of work well good luck in
this life uh and and inevitably if
you're the real deal you know it's uh
life will find its way to you I hope I
hope beautiful comment but thank you but
I think the think this is I me and this
when we met some years ago at a at a
Premiere and we couldn't take our eyes
off each other and I feel like we we see
each other and see what we're truly see
what we're trying to do and how we're
trying to do it and really I think
that's why I feel like you're like a
sister to me in this industry and I
think that and I think I think listen
I've always had so much pride and still
do of being a journeyman it you know my
career has always been like oh one day
I'm doing a show on Broadway next minute
I'm bartending next minute I'm teaching
next minute I'm doing regional theater
next minute I'm but also I I I committed
myself to that early on that's the thing
in the work I
believe tended with the same obsessive
dedication to sort of being a channel
and a vessel I was a good bartender I
was a great bartender I had a good time
you know I turned it in I turned it into
honestly anyone who knows me from
bartending I used to bartending this
place called the 55 bar and in um New
York and I would work you know I had the
worst shifts but I would work from like
nine and this is little I would do a
show shift's best attit wor worship but
I I would do I would do shows like at
Manhattan class company get a CL get a
cap across town and I'm wearing like
probably clothing that probably costs
way more than I'm going to make that
night and I would go there and I bartend
and I was happy at it like so I feel
like that's the thing so I always knew
that wherever I was I had to find the
the place where I'm going to have
fulfillment and feel like I have some
purpose and be joyful and I found it in
in in bars in the West Village and I
would but also mine was a jazzar so I
had like incredible Jazz musicians
coming in and out you know Nora Jones
would sing there and stuff like that so
I had I was getting filled up and then I
was also creating still that didn't stop
creating I was like I was writing plays
when the BART Ed out at 1:00 in the
morning and I was there till 4:00 that's
when I wrote my first solo play I found
ways to continue to be an artist at all
times and for not to feel like it's a
separate thing than like if I'm
bartending I'm not an actor I'm like no
I'm always an artist you know just you
know just it's and it's and it's the way
I had to believe that I had a agency and
how what I believe is the way the life
of an artist is that is that where it
comes so I'm asking for all of us but it
might be a little selfish it's
uh that
deep honest that true sense of gratitude
that you seem to embody that is also you
know I don't see that kind of humility
uh walking around but it's it's humble
because it's sort of uh there's a Joy
about life there's a sort of a a
gratitude for just being in the game and
alive at all and it's almost like a you
know it's musical in its nature it's
it's like The Music of the Spheres you
know what I mean it's it's the most uh
connected kind of thing and I guess were
you always that way cuz it's like I it
was not an easy Road always for Coleman
Domingo unless I'm mistaken so at what
point in this sort of shy guy uh turned
artiste turned a man we see here today
uh did you know you sort of like cracked
that nugget of I gotta was it that did
you know that you had to flip your
perspective or did you were you just
came out the womb that way
that's a great question oh no problem
I'm riffing I'm riffing no but I but I
wonder I was I think I was a happy
baby and I was loved and kissed on a
lot I was adored and and and I didn't
knew I was
um I come from a you know very you know
workingclass family you know went to
college I had to you know have part-time
jobs and work and but I was always I
think I was always grounded with a sense
of um having faith my mother had really
impressed him upon me to have an
imagination they were they religious I'm
just curious no my mother came from a
very Baptist family but she didn't raise
us that way she was like dude she was
she was like do what you want just be a
good person single mom no my mother
married my stepfather when I was 9 years
old but she was you know she was in my
dad for a minute that's a whole other
thing it's whole talk guys guys guys
it's about the movies all right it's not
therapy Bally just give just just giving
you the the grounding of it he's my
therapist in case you guys don't know we
we trick you person life you know we
sorted ranging the New Year together and
Coleman did the countdown It's Kind it's
not a big deal but we have a lot of life
together we go to Mexico and stuff uh
vacation together um but anyway so it's
not a therapy session not your childhood
go on so you have your baby I think that
I was a happy kid and I came from a very
happy household we didn't have a lot but
we had really good times together that's
why I feel like I know how to throw a
good
party CU I think that that's what we did
we we just really enjoyed ourselves so
by the time I went off I when my mother
just wanted me to make sure I did
something that I felt good about that I
was happy doing and once I found the
theater and found this industry like she
may not have known what that was because
she wanted me to have a job of security
like any parent did but I chose this
path and she would couldn't have been
more delighted and curious in what I
want to do how how old were you when you
uh moved to New York and did full-time
I'm going to move to the the the the
real question soon okay guys I put on my
glasses to be official I got to give you
the the roundabout cuz I started I
started my career in San Francisco yes
sir I moved to San Francisco when I was
20 years old I didn't finish school at
Temple University I thought it was going
to take a year off I had one of my
buddies move up to California it was
three guys living living in a studio
apartment and the tender line district
and so I decided to be the
fourth here's a here's a joke for you
but it's the truth I literally lived in
a
closet W though I was never in the
Clos no I was never in it but yet still
but yet still but yet I mean I really
listen there's been so much good fortune
and you know I had that from San
Francisco my friend guy would Barton and
leave his tips and say use it do what
you need to do get a job start doing
what you want to do start taking acting
classes there stuff like that and then I
started to have a career I started to
actually have a career by like showing
up to you know auditioning for things
that I probably had no business
auditioning for no that's a big rule
that people don't got to leave the house
C I was in the circus cus I did you know
Shakespeare festivals I show up to
rehearsals that I wasn't even called in
for because it was it was my
Conservatory I was going to learn
everything I was learning and feeling
and I think that's the way my career has
been about feeling and learning and
evolving and not in sort of a textbook
way yes sir it's sort of like everything
I've learned is by doing and figuring it
out and trialing eror which is why I
think this why the origins of my career
I've had such freedom because I didn't
have a a a rigid way of doing things you
know what I mean so that's why I could
even look at a real and like wow that's
I don't know many people who who
liberate themselves to do so many
different things and to feel like they
could fail at anytime well that's also
why there's so few Originals If we're
honest it's like people think there's a
path to follow but the truth is like be
inside the thing be inside the thing and
try and figure it out and be willing to
fail I we are going to go to a clip in
uh two minutes by the way I think that's
in pencil which is very hard to read uh
so maybe do something like a finger a PE
sign and uh okay uh so I'll just ask one
one official question because why not in
this two minutes um I mean because my
God there's so many things in here like
as a professor how do you approach act I
may we'll get to that um uh uh um among
your numerous nominations and awards is
there one recognition or project that
holds a special place in your heart and
why I can immediately say Yes um uh me
me and my husband we created a short
film just because yeah don't Point him
out he's very shy oh I'm so
sorry God Knows Why bash looking
character there is a there's a short
film that we created just to create
called um New Moon and that was actually
the beginning of the animation and we
created just because we went to create
it was during the pandemic and we want
to create something sort of an offering
of love to the world we didn't know what
we were going to do with it but we uh
created it the two of us uh and two
animators in France that we reached out
to and because we saw their work and we
created this thing we've never been in
the same room with them we created it
all online and then when it was done it
was it was a short piece taken came from
my solo show and it's just about a
mother and son and their relationship to
the moon and ARA
Franklin it's a personal story so we
want that just to put it out in the
world as an offering and I remember my
our business team you know our business
managers and everything were like you're
animation is expensive like no we're
going to take it from our own salaries
and put it into this because this's
something we want to give and we did
that and then we put set up a zoom it
was um actually the anniversary of of my
mother's birth as my mother's birthday
she's been gone since
2006 so it was a gift on Mom's birthday
to share with family and then everyone
loved it and there was tears and they
said what are you going to do with it
we're like well we didn't get that far
we're like we're just going to give it
to the world they're like oh you should
do some film festivals and all so it
went the down the film festival circuit
we figured out how to do that we didn't
know how to anything that we do we
figure out we're we're just Scrappy in
that way but eventually it was um we won
all these beautiful film festivals like
for the Oscar and we're short listed for
the Oscar which is
great that's meaningful for me that's
how it's done it's like be in the work
if the work is the real thing if it
comes from a real deal place it's not
about what happens to it yeah Walks Like
the truth smells like the truth is the
truth and so uh and I tell you wi an
Oscar and uh I'm telling you that cuz I
have a bunch um I I'm really I don't
talk about them uh is there two minutes
are we ready for our clip I believe you
okay um listen I'm I could do this for
literally like six weeks and we like
this is not so I was like an opportunity
to be with Coleman for an hour a half
yes please all right so the first clip
we're going to go to is uh Euphoria this
is an out out I me I love this fuck the
big fucking the dinos scene Jesus I love
this scene I I don't know which clip
we're going to show let's
watch God damn Coleman
God
damn I mean okay like uh you know as a
drug addict in recovery which I feel
like I I can't talk about enough uh like
holy fucking shit I mean it's so heavy
this scene it's so beautifully
articulated and the way that you deliver
it I mean it's got to be poetry it can't
be the fucking ocean it's like you got
to find a power where you're sick and
the way you're doing it and the way Sam
is fucking shooting it uh can you just
tell me how it really hits I I just want
as as the guy who's been in that Diner
and who's been in both spots you know uh
dispensor and thepony H and it's still
deranged as fuck uh despite it and you
are not an addict at all Coleman like
how did you fucking hit this and and you
know and and how did you touch it and
was it all written already with Sam or
did you and Zena kind of work it and and
tell me anything all the things I'm I'll
start here I I first met Sam levenson
the Creator and director and writer of
this um and when when I met him we
immediately started talking in the
corner for like hours this is at a party
and we what I love about Sam is like we
could talk about everything on the
planet what's important to us and what's
really important to us so that's how it
started and he was like I so he wrote
this character for me and he said it's
somebody who really helped him through
and who was you know he had his own
struggles etc etc but also he had a
great philosophy so this was written th
this was actually a conversation that
was spread out over episodes before we
were going to shoot season two but then
the pandemic happened and then
everything was scrapped and then the
first thing back Sam was like I want I
want to do this something he figured out
for him and I'll tell you about playing
it and all that in a second but he said
I want it I want this intimate
conversation just a hard conversation
and I think this couldn't have happened
before the pandemic he was inspired by
the pandemic to pull this together and
say I think we need to sit down and have
a talk a hard talk after a summer of
racial Reckoning as well this the first
time we're back so therefore it's when I
tell you we talked about gratitude you
talked about gratitude I could have been
more grateful to be on a set again to do
what I love and he was he he sent me
this script and it was as if he read my
dark deepest
private uh conversations and hopes and
wishes and concerns
about who we are and who we're going to
be yeah it's about people in recovery
talking and have a conversation but it
really is about America it's about race
it's about what we're addicted to it's
about social media it's about all that
so he's unpacking this is Sam levenson
here and this for me felt like it felt
like such a
prayer it felt like I wanted to give
everything to this so I put myself
through my own rehearsal for like 40
hours a
week before we got to set I didn't know
was what Zenda was doing we got on Zoom
a couple times just to read through and
zindaa is a champion I mean she's a
fucking Rockstar a rock star like that's
somebody who deserves that's like so we
came together we came together truly
with all this I'm so grateful to be here
energy and we're going to go for it and
when I tell you when the cameras rolled
and you see these are scenes that go on
forever it became a one-act play where
it's like we were just going on one
angle going on the other Sam come and
give some direction here and there but
it really was I wanted to get out of the
way in every single way and just say
this is truly in service to all of our
Humanity right now and so did Z we so we
went at it and he let us really do the
dance
together I've had many people in my life
who has been in recovery who
struggle and I and I feel like the best
that we are what we do is to really be
an um empath and to really just say okay
I need to how can I not judge this
person how how how can I understand this
so I can play it and play it I have to
love every character that I play and I
to love all the messed up things about
his own experience he even talks about
in this Diner scene I had to find out
who he was and what he's fighting for
and what he hopes to be and so I think I
just go Ahad and the best when I tell
you the
best thing for me is when
anyone anyone who's gone people always
think they're like they're like oh you
see me You' been in recovery
too and I'll just say I understand you
cuz it's human I that's what a wild
that's what I'm saying as somebody who
is like recovery guy it's like I fucking
I believe that person more it almost
reminds me you guys remember that movie
Fat City with Susan Terrell and Jeff
bridg and Stacy ke it's John Houston
it's like that's like the fucking
alcoholism you know active alcoholism
movie this is like a scene about
recovery like I've never seen in my life
because are the things you're the living
embodiment of the thing that we all need
to hear and you're loving the fact that
like it's okay that we're sick and
broken on the inside does not mean that
we need to take ourselves out yeah like
that seems and that's what gets
transmitted that's the you're a channel
thank you can I ask a question a
specific of course you can sure
uh uh you car character ends the scene
with the line your only hope is a
revolution what does that line mean to
you and I do want to say one thing about
my friend uh Albert Camu who I believe
comes up in Passing Strange as well you
have a line about him I think he say
something like the uh only way to exist
in an unfree world is to become so
absolutely free that your very existence
is an act of
rebellion um that's not on here uh
that's bu deep somewhere in the kid uh
but just to say this line you know what
I mean that's what it fucking Sparks for
me what what did you say that what's the
rest of the line the only hope is a
revolution but not a but I think he he's
really saying not a performative one
everyone think is Revolution is like let
me join this group let me join this let
me sign that letter let me do that he's
said no A revolution is
personal it's actually private and you
have to and you have to dedicate
yourself to it every single day whatever
that is the revolution starts with you
you know and it's not on Twitter and
it's not because you did a
post
shit I think I think this is that's the
beautiful thing that Sam Sam is putting
out he's putting a lot of arguments out
there like think about this think about
are you a revolutionary are they really
a revolutionary because they suddenly
it's you know it's if if it's gay pride
month and suddenly they got a flag up
you think they really actually believe
or are they trying to get you money he's
telling you to look deeper
that's that's what I loved about all of
it because he was like now that
especially as we were coming out of the
pandemic he was like examine all of this
really look because said he said we're
all sick every single one of us in this
room everyone who you know who if you
think if you think it's just about being
an addict because of drugs or alcohol or
sex you're lying to yourself so I think
he's like examine our culture
deconstruct it for yourself and really
think and inquire and interrogate he's
actually I think that's why this episode
in particular is so potent for people
and people go to it over and over again
it's it's one of the FV my favorite
things I've ever done yeah cuz I really
felt like and maybe that's it it's
because I still feel so very emotionally
connected to it I could barely watch it
because I think of it was that time with
me where you know we're watching you
know George Floyd and you know we're
trying to figure out are we going to be
able to hug each other again or anything
like that and we're also terrified and
then some then this script comes to me
and I'm like this is it this is my
Lifeline it's a Lifeline for everyone
and so I poured everything into it and
so did zindaa and so did Sam so it does
feel like it's that thing where we're
like here are the questions that we're
wrestling with in this culture right now
go deeper well I think that what you're
speaking to is and are you GNA give me a
hand signal okay are we there yet or we
have
a ah o Zola's coming up you know I like
that one um but uh yeah I mean it really
is this thing of you know on the deepest
level it's like the real gig is and the
reason it doesn't matter if it's
directing writing acting in your case is
fucking I mean uh you know I know the
movie that you were writing when we were
hanging out in Puerto viarta the house
was sick uh and uh but you know you're
also like I mean you know you can play
all the instruments you can fucking do
any I mean like but really what you're
transmitting is uh this thing that's
like uh a way of saying to the person
that's watching that's not to you know
winning things and all this glitterati
around it somehow you're really in
communion with the act of service of
like one soul to another who is a sick
and suffering person at home watching
who fucking needs to hear it and that is
what you're transmitting in the work
that I think is so rare and uh the
result is uh well you got a prime time
Emmy Award uh um and uh but you
know once in a blue moon you know it's
for the fucking really really really
right reasons you know what I mean it's
like and it's it's deep because you know
it's like a lost art form I think in our
modern world I think you're
right thank you H
well um I guess we could uh transition
um
but it's big it's really big stuff
Coleman I mean it really is it's like
the idea that one person is sitting at
home watching that and that makes it
them make it through a day you know what
I mean that's what's so crazy about what
we do there's a young woman who um sent
me a message and I'll never forget it
and it really touched me so deeply she
said after watching that episode I
finally understood my mother who passed
away some years ago and she um suffered
from the disease of addiction and he
said she said for the first time I was
able to
see her and her struggle and to
understand it was a disease it wasn't
her but it got the better of her and I
thought about I remembered her wanting
to be a ballerina and her dancing and
that she had dreams and aspirations like
everyone else and she says so now it
allowed me to forgive her and and she it
was it's big and it is it is a rotten
like you know Soul sickness it is a
diseased country it is a diseased world
it's like I mean our country say
literally a Native American burial
ground and we're all just like hanging
out on it being like why do the problems
keep coming up well you know what I
mean what's going on in the world why we
got these wars it's like well you know
capitalism is a fucking rotting Soul
sickness so maybe it's that uh and maybe
is an empath maybe it's like we're
feeling that and so you know cuz often
it's like like yeah yeah man uh yeah
Em's weekend yeah uh the ask is oh yeah
here you go you're winning at life and
it's like but is a fucking worldwin I
mean it's a the job is to be in
communion with the fucking ether and how
everybody is you know collapsing on the
inside so it's a weird thing to you know
I I I much admire that about you that
it's so over that you're um uh
communicating with the fact that we
don't all feel great even though and
that the way you like shine through that
is with this sort of you know sort of
like a positivity of like guys like I
will help shoulder you let's get on the
ride because we got to push through this
thing as a team well you know what I I I
speak to something you just mentioned
too because it's funny and I'll just say
this there's this you know right now
it's a yeah it's a very um
glittery time when it comes to being out
there for awards weeks and stuff like
that and it's funny because I think that
people keep asking me how you doing how
you feeling yeah and wondering how it's
affecting you and all that and to be
very honest I know that it's
opportunities to go into rooms and
actually communicate with others it's
like I I don't want for
anything I don't I actually don't I want
to communicate and get to know and say
hello so I walk in people like you walk
in dress and you're having a good time
you look like you're actually having a
good time and the truth is I
am and I and I and so it's my question
when other people aren't having a good
time I'm like well what are you focused
on I'm focused on
like many things and I think that you
know one in particular I think and I'll
just say the one thing I think I'm I'm
focused on is the fact that it's not
just me in these rooms it's all these
people have come with me that have
poured into me
so I have to honor that by having a good
time by smiling and enjoying and shaking
hands and getting to know people and
knowing my community and being and
someone saying some kind words to me and
actually
listening and actually taking in this
moment because that's all it's about
it's not about the outcome it's just not
it's about right now and what are we
doing right now and so I think that
that's it it's like I'm always very
concerned with going back to service
yeah what and whatever I do cuz I feel
like that's where're at our best when we
throw a part we throw New Year's Eve
party together by the way no big deal
guys because I real because we do this
we we're sort of this interesting couple
of people who she opens couple
yeah because she opens her home and she
won't say it but she opens her home
because she's really helping Community
to engage with one another and I know I
can be a partner with that so we we it
just made sense we're like great I got
you I'm going to do the decorations and
this you open the home you you plan this
well we know our superpowers because
we're actually trying to do the same
thing I think that's why we're dedicated
to it you know and then also we're
dedicated to a good sleigh of clothes as
well why not I mean
what but you know because it it is it's
a big deal I mean this stuff is is is
big boy shit it's not about self you can
either be on the journey that's even you
know what you're saying in the scene
that is if it's a journey of self for
you know the end end end all big is my
ego I'm going to win at like it's like
we're all going to die spoiler alert you
know what I mean like there's no there
there you can win what you want make the
money like you know you can't fucking
keep it or you can enjoy this ride and
actually be mindful and present and
enjoyful know that like people are
fucking you know hurting and it's a
anyway it's a it's a it's a very rare
rare thing in our our business to be
that's why I was so grateful to get to
do this with you is I was like you're
telling me there's an opportunity in the
middle of all these Shenanigans to
actually sit and talk to you about this
stuff like oh man that sounds like a
grounding fucking event to do before we
head off to our next fucking you know
small talk that we always will try to
make big talk
um all right let's go to
uh I can say if I really I could do this
all day I I I'm grateful too that you
guys are willing and shed notes if you
hate what's
happening cuz it's kind of going to be
this Vibe for like another solid 40 or
longer we don't know uh anyway um so uh
as we get into Zola it is important to
know that uh I mean janix
Bravo is a a heavy hitter in the extreme
I mean this is a human being who is so
singular who is such a genuine otor who
really has a vision and can articulate
it and in writing this with her uh you
know best friend baby brother our
soulmate Jeremy o' Harris uh who is I
mean this is a fucking radical brain
Jeremy like that is a big brain nobody
can drop you I drop C Mo like it was I
mean Jeremy wipe the floor with that uh
so anyway I love these guys it's also
how I met you so it makes me love you
everybody even more I love this film I
love your performance in it I love how
it's shot H I guess let's show a clip
right and get into it Zola baby janix
braavos
Zola
yeah I feel like I'm sort of dressed
like him right
now kind of inspired
I mean this character like when you drop
the fucking game and you switch over oh
my God that switch is one of the crazier
things I think I've ever seen on film
that was wild it was wild listen janix
what I loved about working with her she
really let my freak flag fly she really
allowed me to really create the
character that I wanted to it's based
off of you know it's based off of um a
Twitter threat but
and but then I had to really you know I
had to really do some deep psychological
work about like I had to study you know
being a pimp and you know and and sex
trafficking and all that stuff and I go
down this whole rabbit hole and that was
the wildest thing because I'm I'm
absolutely a feminist and I'm such a you
know I'm like I'm not that person but I
was like but I was curious about it
espec I was curious because also janix
the thing that I did before that I
thought was very popular was if Bill
Street could talk and I'm like the most
loving father and supporter of young
women and then janix she met with me and
said oh my God I got the script and I
was like whoa who's thinking of me for
this there's nothing in my U that that
has shown that I can do this and I met
with janix and she's like oh com I I
just think you can do anything and I was
like really I okay and then I like I saw
her little weird bra cuz she she's she
she'll get this look that's sort like a
maniac and you're like I think I want to
be a maniac with you so we went down
this rabbit hole and we really helped
create this character and I just had a
great time creating G gave he had such
AG I had to find out what I loved about
him too I did I took well maybe the
character you play that's most unlike
you frankly is that true yeah unless you
ask like people like my friend of Mel
who says I love taking people to strip
clubs which is but strip clubs honey
that's just a nice time you know what I
mean this guy is a fucking piece of work
he's a piece of work but I took it from
I had to my own secret for for the
character was like I had to take it um I
like the question that people don't know
if he's actually Nigerian or he's
africanamerican but I always like to
believe that he was coming from the
point of view of it was an immigrant
story and everyone else was the
villain he was like I'm just trying to
get paid and get the American dream like
everybody else and I'm using what I know
to be true which is sex trafficking
women God what a fucking brilliant way
in because I'm like he's see he thinks
everyone else is a villain and he just
trying to do his do his work yeah and be
in
service yeah Hannibal Lector is like
listen I'm just trying to eat and I'm
just trying to eat I don't know what
everybody else's problem which is why
he's like why are you taking so long we
have to go yeah what are you do I'm
trying to run a business here yeah and
you know and then you just do what I say
trying to help you I'm trying to help
you I'm trying to I that's a bag of
money he gave her yes he said he gave
her a bag of money that he even gave her
a gun he said I don't know what more I
can give you to to help you out but the
deep cut of Asian immigration story but
he has a fake Nigerian accent yes exact
it's got to be one of the other I
believe he was I made the choice that he
was actually Nigerian but he was
actually he wanted to to believe people
to believe he was just some
African-American dude H so it would drop
every so often in in a crazy way and
then he would have to cover it up like
the first time I do it I cover it I'm
like I I got I I got he has to get it
back cuz he knows the Secret's been out
but then he starts to use it in a I love
that he used it in a strange way sort of
I feel like it's a power move too yeah
he's like you never know who he is or
what he's going to do so he's and even
like we we genexa help had me do some
beautiful weird things like when I'm in
the bathroom I would she said could you
make some noises or something while
you're in the bathroom because the scene
is happening and the camera's on them
yet she still wanted me to dominate the
scene no matter what his presence so I'm
in the I'm in the bathroom
peeing and I remember I saw this I went
into back of a theater in Austin Texas
just to watch this film and I was in
front of these three girls and they were
watching the scene and I'm in the if you
seen the movie I'm in there you hear me
going while I'm peeing and I heard them
go oh my God you're so he's so fucking
gross and I just died I'm like yes he is
he's
[Laughter]
gross cuz they're like I like the
questions like what's wrong WR with him
what's going on what's Happening down
there you
know that guy takes up space he that's
how he pisses
uh and your girlfriend in this movie is
fucking great I mean she baby yeah she
was C the beautiful thing is janix did
some beautiful snut casting she cast her
off of Instagram yeah because she was
one of those you know beautiful she's
wonderful beautiful curvaceous models
and she was like 6' three and like 20
35 lbs the two of you together were
fucking IM and I love that you know it's
it's a character that you don't even
know her name she just shows up in the
third act out of nowhere with a gun yeah
and I was like yes and please and you're
say yeah happy to see you you're like
baby's back H uh yes so um let's see
what these are I'm trying to think some
of these we really cover oh uh I guess
it say here you worked with Taylor Page
on this project uh how was uh The
Experience different from Mar rain's
black bottom well the wildest thing is
this we
shot Zola first first time we ever work
together that intimately and then we did
Mar's black bottom together and that was
um first of was just the beautiful thing
is you know you stand it long enough you
know these people become part of your
acting company and she's she's so lovely
and wonderful to work with so we were
she really has become my my baby sister
in many ways so uh it was just nice to
go from that this very Art House Alt
film to this very Prestige film directed
by George C wolf and to find how we're
useful in that space which is beautiful
with my co-stars travick B Boseman and
and Via Davis and Glenn Turman and
Michael Potts we I feel like we created
something really special and um I don't
know well on um and we'll get to George
D wolf uh um a lot today um but uh I
love what you said about this idea like
just even the villain I think it's just
true of everybody in this life like and
it's so hard to remember like even in uh
in politics you know they talk about
whatever these like Echo chambers that
we get into with our fucking algorithms
and all this shit and oh everybody must
think the same thing right and it's like
oh no there's a whole other flip and
they the exact opposite and so people
really believe what they believe and
they believe that they are right
everybody else is the head space of
someone who's a villain and then how do
you humanize them so you can understand
who they are I do that I have another
film called like The Color Purple I'm
playing Mister who's very much gorgeous
performance Coman I love that movie and
Danielle Brooks my God our our our dear
Danielle Brooks but but I had to come to
the perspective of like you know Mister
is a broken person he's a hurt person
hurting people so I have to get into the
psychology of like he has dreams once
like everybody else yeah and what
happens when his dreams were deferred he
put his foot on the neck of someone else
so for me in order to find I have to
find the heart and Humanity of every
character I don't have to play Heroes I
can play Such dastardly human beings got
to find out what what makes them tick
for me it's maybe that's the question
like because I'm always trying to figure
out like I'm one of those people that
like when I go to hotel rooms I watch
very different news networks yeah you
know new news networks that spew back
things I like to hear and things that I
don't really like to hear because I want
to figure them out as well I want to
figure out well what are they exactly
why do they believe that and then if I
can if if my job as an artist and our
jobs are inter to interrogate that that
can become more human and I can I can
actually learn to have a conversation
with and we can find ways to heal I
guess I think I think I do that I I
remember I was doing that in my my
makeup chair when I was on Fear The
Walking Dead and we we have people some
one young woman who did my makeup and
she absolutely we weren't aligned in
many
ways politically hey there's a lot of
story there was a lot of story we
weren't aign but honestly we were able
to have the because we loved each
other and I and I love her and I do and
she loves me but we were able to find to
Bridge and find ways I would ask her a
question why do you why do you believe
that why do you think that and I was and
not with a lot of noise lot not with a
lot of Huff but I know that we're able
to I was able to understand her and she
was able to understand me and hopefully
we're moving the needle a bit more I
think that's what our jobs are as artist
I think that is how change works right
it does work it doesn't work that you
yell at somebody or I was told this
about like uh PTSD that you um a lot of
people think uh with PTSD or something
it's like a there's a a smell in the
room and automatically you're like boom
you're back and it's sort of like you
know um it you hear the sound of a
fucking a great and a taxi and boom
you're in Vietnam again or what whatever
it is in my case my childhood uh and uh
then you're all of a sudden you're down
in this kind of pit down there and the
well and a lot of people think that you
can just sort of yell over and say hey
why are you so sad life's going great
come on out but in fact what this world
needs is what you're talking about with
the makeup artist is what you're talking
about this weigh in of believing that
even the villain has a point of view and
a rayon the fucking epigenetic fucking
that's how they got there you got to go
sit down walk down there quietly sit
next to them in the well hang out with
them even hold their hand once just
fucking hang out out a while and like
when they're done and they're like all
right maybe uh yeah let's walk up out of
here maybe I'm a little maybe let's walk
up and you kind of walk up together and
then it's okay you know what I mean like
it's not you know you're this way and
you got to fix it and like that does not
seem to actually Change Change the World
um are we I see uh so uh we're throwing
to a clip yeah we're throwing to a clip
but yeah fucking Zola is incredible oh
and one last thought straight thought um
we'll go over by about three hours today
uh don't panic and uh it's just like in
some ways like are you kind of like a
Jack
Nicholson to us because the thing about
uh Jack Nicholson I think about like a
Five Easy Pieces or whatever is that he
had a sort of a you know like a light in
his eyes a kind of like a sparkin and a
mischief and what he would do that would
make the fucking the camera just like
that come alive in such a wild way and
when I see you in Zola but also just
watching this Euphoria and also knowing
you it's like there's this sort of lean
back cool but there's a sense of like I
mean this is a serious perform we love
to watch and I don't know it's just
always it's so Sparky as opposed to you
know some performers are kind of a you
know
if I'm being honest right s of like
congratulations I hope you win your
award and God bless in your life please
don't make me watch this uh but you know
I mean like Jack really has that thing
where you're like oh it's going to be
I'm in for a ride I I think I think I
think some require that and a sort of
that that spark and that fire and fuel
in the eyes and some require you to just
be um to fall back a bit more and I
think yeah I that's that's what I think
I feel it all depends on the the what
what's required actually I think well
this is a gorgeous segue cuz let's see
some uh My Rainy black
bottom
whoa drink
water um okay a lot of things first of
all Chadwick holy fuck I'm sorry I see
you uh crying
Coleman and uh I've never seen that film
in a theater ever it just dawned me I
was like I it's I've never seen it in
this size and to see Chad's eyes and all
that it's just
uh it is what it is I mean that is um I
I I I feel you I not in the same way
because I never met him I don't know him
I uh well this scene in particular this
this scene in particular this film is
directed by George Seawolf
and he really put us together we had an
intense rehearsal period of three
weeks and when Chad first saw me I'd
knew Chad for years but we never worked
together and he said oh man I can't wait
to dance with
you and that's what we're doing truly
yeah and um that scene affects me
because there was some there was some
lots of layers happening in that scene
and that was a scene where and this is
actually the take
where George staged at like a boxing
ring in many ways and we had our corners
and we Retreat to it Etc go back and
then it was com combustible and in
particular on that day I'll never forget
that scene for the rest of my life
because there was something else at work
I I didn't know that my my friend was
ill as ill as he was cuz he was very
sick at that time I didn't know this no
one knew which is like he was a
superhero so I remember we
were he was going through that monologue
when God hates and that goes blah blah
blah and he stopped he sort of paused
and there was something happening that
was if anybody works with me I'm like
it's the real it's that stuff that you
can't that Sam Shepard would say no uh
John Patrick Shanley would say to leave
room for the Divine to reside mhm and in
that moment there was something
happening there and he was almost afraid
of it the language what was happening
what it's about faith it's about a
crisis of faith and he started to he
started to turn away and I said what
what in character and I started yelling
at him and said say it say it say it say
it and then he turns to me with that
look in his face and he's got and Guy
hates niggas got and he continues that
monologue we that's takes on both of us
right there and then knock punch him and
then after afterwards we come back in
the door closes and George calls cut and
I it honestly I it wasn't set up this
way at all we just immediately embraced
each other and started sobbing ah and we
didn't know what was it was silent in
the room it was absolutely silent and we
just stood there and
cried and and was silent the whole
crew and I remember
after we didn't know what was
happening and then suddenly Glenn Turman
said Glenn terman is a legend he's been
around for a long time he said never in
my years have ever seen anything like
this because it was and I think and I
look back at it now that as an artist
whether it's Coleman whether it's Cutler
but I needed to be in service and help
my friend at that moment and push
whatever that was
out and he let me because it was a safe
space for it of Rage of frustration
that's all I can imagine it was now he's
not here to validate any of this but
these are the questions I was left with
was like what was that what was that
about that we all experienced and it was
about a crisis of faith in the room the
characters were having it and then the
actors something was happening and in
that moment we had to be in service to
each other in that way and let that
thing happen and we'll never forget it
that's what that's what we were like
this after that we were already close
and and then you know after we wrapped I
I didn't see Chad again after we wrapped
and he sent me a lovely Christmas gift
and a card and it's a record player that
I have and they I love you and I look
forward to dancing with you
again and then he was
gone but but he left such a great you
know Legacy in many ways not only in
this work but just in what he did in the
world but you know we get yes please
but I'll tell you this because that you
didn't even ask this but I don't know
why I want to say this I realize because
we're talking about service a lot
already early on yeah and we never know
we I I always asked whether you know
whether it's
the spiritual folks that would say let
let God use you be in service and in
that moment is those moments you're like
I hope I'm used in this moment as a this
is what I do as an actor you know what I
mean and I mean that's the addictive
part people don't talk about it's like
when you have a moment where you're just
sort of you actually disappear like I've
I've been doing this for 40 years I can
like I think maybe three times it's
happened and it's like a hundred fucking
movies 99 of them are unwatchable uh and
uh but uh but when it happens but when
it happens you're like oh that's acting
yeah you disappear and that's what it's
something else is that play something
else like enters your fucking Spirit
yeah and like you and Chadwick I mean
like it's it's and it's pretty major I
mean it really is like uh the most
uncynical version of like a life in the
Arts and why it's a fucking thing and
why it
matters uh you personally in that scene
what's so crazy is like the physiognomy
you know I mean like that your eyeballs
are actually not the same eyeballs as
the man we just saw in Zola they are not
the same eyeballs as the man we saw in
the diner and they're not my friend
Coleman's eyeballs like and it's also
your physical body like you physically
have taken like you're taking up space
it's like you know you got to have bad
and uh I've seen it in was sort of like
a European bathing suit uh and H when we
go to the beach uh so uh you should know
that and uh anyway but you are fucking
using that body to either be like a lean
mean fucking power tailor we're going up
and like I'm a big guy or you're using
it to be like hey man I'm just hanging
back and I like you know uh snacks and
life and fucking music or you're using I
mean you're using it to be like I'm I'm
an addict so I was probably like a wiy
guy at some point when I was strung out
but now I sort of like I'm eating
grilled cheese sandwiches and doing a
life of service like it's fucking crazy
and I think is Wonder crazy but I but
you know what I think that's the joy of
it too I've always had to find the body
The Voice the astrological sign the
choices of what I eat how I eat how they
have sex all all that stuff that you
will never ever know I like to make
decisions about and down download cuzz
you'll know it in some way you'll feel
it so for me it's more about the essence
in creating this whole tapestry of a
human being that you where I can recede
that's been also sort of like my
superpower for many years for many years
people think I just got here like last
week yeah I right now people are like oh
my God Coleman I've never seen him in
any work you're like actually you might
have and then they go back they go back
and further back and they're like he's
been working for 33 years I know it's
crazy he been right there this Prodigy
is fucking hitting no cuz you it's like
cuz I know it's like oh no I Chang my
body I gain weight I lose weight I look
older I look younger I you know I smile
I don't smile I I pitch my voice in
different ways and that's been a great
superpower for a while you know what I
mean where it's like which is why people
like wow it's taking you a while I'm
like yeah people couldn't couldn't put a
pen on me yeah you know because I was
constantly like I was Wy in that way
yeah but I was also that's been great
because I've always been liberated I I
haven't had to
live up to something I've done before
could you even imagine if you're like
that's a fucking toll yeah like you know
how people get locked into that thing
you're that thing we like that thing and
they don't want you to be anything else
but that thing I'm not that guy which is
awesome people was like here play this
water bottle that's interesting if I got
to play that water bottle one more
fucking time I uh can you tell me a bit
about um and please my friend um I'm
sorry what's your name I'm sorry Kate Hi
Kate Kate we're uh um are you about
ready for that cuz I uh I just have one
more question that might be a nice uh
segue and I love a segue uh and uh but I
don't know what an actual like a segue
in the futurism sense is I know it
exists but I I don't know about it um I
think it's a moving vehicle of some sort
I'm not going to get on it I uh uh
George C wolf uh because we're going to
move over to uh uh our big boy here
Rustin uh and and can you tell me yes
please go ahead
thanks uh can you please tell me uh uh
about the first time you met George if
if anybody who doesn't know uh speaking
as a New Yorker uh George Seawolf is you
know as big a guy as we've got in the uh
New York theater scene so he's on your
radar as a as a as a kid you know
because the New York Times the paper
back when we had a paper and uh
so he's a fucking major major when I
first met George I Met George when um
many times I audition for him like five
times he'll refute that he thinks no you
never audition him like yes I did and I
never I never got cast which I was fine
with and life goes on and then I get an
offer like a direct offer to be a part
of maren's black bottom and I thought it
can't be from George C the George CA
wolf CU he doesn't like my
work but it was he actually he you know
I think he's very specific about
sort of the bands that he creates and he
and and the way he's creating with music
and he lets these artists come to him so
that was my first time working with him
was Marin black black bottom and then um
the film Rustin had been swarming around
for a while it was in the hands of a
couple of artists before then you know
schedules and all move around and I had
meetings with producer was it always the
Obama's uh not no eventually it was the
Obama's but this this is when it was
just getting traction is a script yeah
and an idea and I had for for years
people had said to me when they do a
biopic about Bayer
Rustin it should be you this happened
for years and I knew about B Rustin and
I know many people didn't I knew about
him since I was 19 years old and I
learned about him in an African-American
Student Union um group and I was
fascinated with them because I felt like
wow he he was really an outlier and did
some incredible things but I also
understood he was marginalized in the
history books because he was openly gay
so I think that he in some way he made
an impression on me because it was even
helping me the way I navigated the way I
was in the world to actually lead with
my intelligence and heart and all that
stuff and trust that I will find the
spaces and I will you know find the
spaces where I'm useful so we uh finally
it moved into George's hands this this
script and project when the Obamas green
L it you know um Barack and
Michelle my dear friends dear
friends so they they um once they green
lit it uh George wolf um he did some
thinking and I got a phone call when I
was away on a little vacation but from
Bruce Cohen our producer who said on
behalf of President Barack Obama
Michelle
Obama Higher Ground and George CA wolf
we will be honored if you would be our
bu
Rustin
and I will tell you for any artist out
there you know if you ever get the
opportunity to play your hero what you
want to
do you wanted to make it your mission
and your life's work that if you didn't
do anything else again it was all in
this
film and that's the reality I wanted to
give everything I could knowing that I
um had this Monumental task for
this man of size of Charisma and heart
and passion and fire and Fuel and
potency and who gave so much and
dedicated his life to human and civil
rights and I get to tell it oh I want to
give you everything and then I also want
to take on the responsibility to lead
the film in a way that may have not have
been done before to lead it like byard
would to be filled with love and grace
and generosity so it was like that was
the task and I feel very honored and
blessed and boy I've been getting so
much much love in rooms because of it
and I can't tell you that that love has
been keeping me buoyant every single day
so I'm not
tired I remember you to go ahead please
we love Applause you know cuz we're
professionals from show so uh we live
for it we need your love uh uh but I
remember you talking about that um well
maybe you remember this too but uh it
was a you know the experience of also
leading as a leader on that set of why
it mattered and I mean my God I don't
know what clip we're about to watch but
it's like that whole fucking you know
moment that tracks throughout the whole
film of uh you know kind of like should
we um not tell people about ruson should
we like sort of bury him in the
background and fucking you standing up
for yourself and like oh God it's so
gorgeous I mean uh let's watch a clip
and see what happens uh and then we'll
talk about other thoughts uh there are
many
woohoo calling the
Mingo they either believe in Freedom and
justice for all or they do
not what a question to pose to people
right I mean it's big and it's like in
in that moment with all of the that's
happening in the world in that moment
that this guy is like fucking standing
up and saying that
is heavy stuff
um and you are an entirely different
person I mean just on an acting level
like what the
fuck that is not you that is like the
spirit of this man has entered and said
like hey thanks for find finding the
right guy cuz I do have a story to tell
and I appreciate that
uh you found the right guy um thank
you yeah well on behalf of rustin's
ghost you're welcome uh I don't think we
knew that was coming I'm not sure that's
legal to say his ghost entered you for a
moment to yes and I uh who knew it was
coming and uh I'm sure it's problematic
can't wait uh uh
yeah and she was like on The Ghost and
Rustin and the Obama's called it was on
Twitter and luckily she was also a
journeyman so we kind of didn't notice
we knew she was nuts uh all right so uh
I mean some of these we've sort of
talked about uh um okay maybe not this
all right so I I'll just run through
some of these so you've heard them H
okay it was not your first film with
George Sea Wolf we know
uh what did it mean to be cashed I think
it meant a lot I'm guessing uh can you
talk about the rehearsal process and
what that looked like for you and the
cast absolutely
n thank you first of all can we give it
up to natas Leon please thank
you hey I'm just here for free fucking
partying with my friend
Coleman listen uh George wolf is like I
said he's from the theater and he he
requires a rigorous rehearsal so I had
uh I had two and a half weeks of
rehearsal beforehand of just table work
just with the cast sitting around
getting this work done and then I now
before then of course I had like the
bulk of the dialogue and I'm on like
pretty much every page of the script so
I needed I need to go in my own process
already of just making sure at of
speeches do you work with anyone do you
ever work with like an acting coach or a
voice a dialect I think that stuff is
private well the dialect work I did work
did I work with a dialect coach on this
Ro did he I did not you're shrugging no
you know why I didn't I didn't because
because in all of my Rec uh recordings
and video of by Rustin his dialect kept
changing and I was so confused by it so
therefore I I asked uh asked someone
asked relle Horowitz who's actually
featured in the film what was that
dialect because at times it would sound
like he would sound like Katherine heurn
and there are times he sound like I
don't know Betty Davis and then there
are times he sound like the Queen of
England so I was like what is this act
and then times it went away now he's
from Westchester
Pennsylvania and he has a thin reier
voice than I it was pitched higher
higher than it's actually that I use it
in the film his his voice was a bit more
up here and he would speak like this I'm
by rtin it was very high and that's a
lot to maintain I didn't want it to feel
like that could feel like a caricature
yeah and so we wanted to find this
middle ground right so find that place
where it sits but he's his accent he
made
up he made up his accent and it's the
truth he was speak he I much respect to
him he was already such an outlier he
was a Quaker he sang Elizabeth and love
songs he played the
loot he did all this stuff and gave
himself an accent I thought that's one
dope motherfucker yeah for real you cuz
really I'm plan on doing that this year
by the way you think of that you're like
someone who's like already not really
sort of invited into rooms and spaces
and he's like I'm going to demand that
and add some add belt and jacket you
know so so I think that's that was part
of um his power of owning his power of
being so unique so in my research and
everything finding his voice finding his
body the way he sat the way he moved his
body you know and for me I always do
this work as well I'm like yeah somebody
in 1963 they weren't working out like
the way I work out they weren't
intermittent fasting so I changed my
diet yeah I changed my diet I you know
if he's got a little bit more heft in
the face and stuff like that yes it's
because I think that's I wanted to eat
the way the way he ate and move like he
did so in anyway so you you as a as a
person can sort of recede and the
character can take his rightful place so
I did all that work beforehand but I had
five I had five months of um prep so I
worked all the time on that and then
once I was in the room we had rehearsals
and then we also had rehearsals before
every single scene and I mean for our
filmakers here these were private
rehearsals and not private with a DP and
a first ad and scrip supervisor in there
these were private it was just director
and actors so therefore we could you
have people like alrey McDonald Jeffrey
Wright coming in and being able to play
it isn't about the end result it's say
oh we're able to actually discover and
find the truth
that we found right here not some
manufactured truth we're able to be
vulnerable and find something brand new
so that's why I think the scenes are
popping and and and electric with each
other because we were finding them I
could play I could play any scene a
hundred different ways because George
liberated me to do so I yeah I don't
think people know that that they're like
they always think it's like about
something or whatever it's like no no
you can do a scene it's like a scene
about a fucking Vape you can do a movie
about the fucking whatever and it's all
uh inside of the the details and like
the sort of the air in the room you get
the details you get the details you get
the research you get all that stuff and
then it's about leaving the room for the
leaving room for the Divine toide you
know and then you can say or do anything
um did you spend time with his widow uh
with a Walter Nagel I I waited yeah
Walter Nagle um first of all I have I
just got sidebar I had the beautiful
gift to go to BU rustin's apartment
which is still fully furnished where is
it it's in Penn Station South in New
York and Chelsea and it's partner Walter
Nagel so you know still lives there
there's still all this religious
sculpture and books and everything that
byed had I sat in by's chair wow it's
all there it's all preserved in such a
gorgeous way and when you go there it's
really interesting so I spent I wanted
to wait until I built this character
because I was very clear I'm not doing a
documentary I'm building a character and
I respect and love and I wanted them I
want I wanted to please them yes but I
had a job to do as taking part of a film
so I waited until I didn't talk to
either one of them really I talked to
relle sooner than Walter but I didn't
talk to Walter until actually um two
days before we wrapped um uh the clip is
very powerful as uh can you say it you
said cuz I was going to say Bayard but
that's not what you said byard thank you
uh Bard's words are still very relevant
today can you talk more about why was
now the right time for a film about
byard Rustin well I think it's always
been a time for a film about Byer Rustin
for
yeah and the the the the well I'll tell
you this it was going to come out last
year but because of covid stops and
starts the film got pushed and I think
everything's Divine CU it is because it
did come out on the 60th anniversary of
the march in Washington holy shit and so
it was an opportunity now to sort of
like not rewrite history but like open
up the history books and move the camera
a little left and look at his story and
look at his legacy and what he did what
he gave and how he inspired Dr King in
many ways and so I feel like the time is
especially now when legislation is
trying to send us right back to
1963 when books are being banned
and history is and history is like up in
question and then so I think it's the
most beautiful thing Natasha is when we
go to Art right um there's a a wonderful
artist in San Francisco named rodessa
Jones who said once and it affected me
so much he says politics doesn't work
religion is too eclectic but art art
just might be the parachute that saves
us all when we can go to Art in in a
safe place like film to interrogate
to question to wrestle in a dark space
together in a community things can
actually change we can actually
hopefully Inspire someone out there some
19 or 20 year old to say you can take
part you have agency you you can
actually do something why because you're
looking on that screen and you're seeing
that the March on Washington was
organized by 19 and 20 year
olds they were you they they didn't know
that they could do it or not but they
were ambitious and they were open and
they were willing to take part in their
democracy and and writing the the wrongs
of this world so I think that's why the
film is important especially right now
at least for me it's really important
right now I want every young person to
see it I want every when people say oh I
haven't seen rusy yet well why not it's
on
Netflix it's 90 it's like 100 minutes
watch it because because also I think
sometimes people are afraid of like oh I
don't want to feel bad oh it's about
civil rights I don't want to feel bad
but for anyone who's watched this film
I'm like it's a buoyant sexy
interesting fun film about
organizing it's GNA get you
hot it is it's a hot picture the kids I
I've really cried in that last fucking
moment when he's just like after all
that organizing with those kids and that
is the wine now of it and and that's
fucking picks up but that's one of my
favorite moments that's actually one of
my favorite moments in the entire script
because he he he doubled down on a
dedication of service yeah he may not
get the shine he may not get to go to
the White House he may get you know
pushed or erased in the history books
but that's Everlasting getting up and
doing the work and I think this is what
any journeyman would know anyone who
could have gotten the shine in their
careers or their workplace in any way
shape or form and didn't get it but to
rededicate yourself to the
work that's powerful that's where we
have true power and then whatever else
comes and if it comes like right now
which is a beautiful thing to me I feel
very blessed that I feel like my work's
being Amplified at the same time as Byer
Rustin if that isn't being in dedication
to service I don't know what is I feel
so blessed and honored that I get to
raise up an American hero and anytime
someone sees me they see him that is the
goal I think of being a journeyman of
doing the work and being dedicated and
dedicated to the work that's why do what
I
do Coleman you are a a beautiful human
being and uh an extraordinary uh artiste
to the max in every fiber your being I'm
so grateful that I get to walk in this
life with you it's really a a lucky
break for me uh and uh I want to thank
everybody that uh is here today that we
got to have a real conversation not one
of these two-minute uh jibber jabber
talks I hate those uh and uh I mean this
is a really beautiful thing that we uh
got to spend some time together I'm so
grateful for the work and and your
existence in the Arts and and I uh I
really I love you very very much and I
love this performance and I'm I'm so
glad that it's being uh appropriately
recognized so all the way to the top
please uh and and uh thank
you guys thank you for uh sticking it
out and uh I mean that about takes us uh
I guess you and I are about to go into
the night Sir yeah we we got to you know
we got we got to go do nighttime things
yeah but I want to say thank you so much
for coming this is very meaningful to me
to share this and I hope that if
anything I hope that whatever some of my
path and my journey inspires you and
um yeah thank
you give yourselves a hand of a round of
applause thank you
[Music]
thanks